call me dude Z you ever see that movie M
Night Shyamalan there's a guy in it I
believe played by John Leguizamo I think
who has worked out one of his arms to be
bigger than all the others that's great
poetry is big business I have generated
five poems about Robert De Niro's
astonishing fascination with the movie
The Crow and crows generally will you
must read them as Robert De Niro this is
croatree with Robert De near Corral
begin
tremendous okay Robert De Niro's
fascination with the movie The Crow and
crows generally I don't think Robert de
Camaro has a fascination with the Crow
movie or crows in general but Robert de
nirk probably does maybe I can't wait
for this holy [ __ ] and we've done Robert
de nirkrow uh have I has he ever yeah I
guess he just talks about the crow
that's it that's Robert de nirko he's
like yeah I'm a crow
Robert de nirkrow of course was when I
lost a challenge or whatever My
Punishment my shame was to dress up in
Cosplay as the crow yeah and once we did
that we were doing all sorts of other
fun bits and when I'm a crawl yeah the
near Crow so now you got to read some
all right so this is in the doozy folder
hold on
croatree
and here it is
here's some chromes
let me uh let me get a sip of my my
water from you hey if you want a sticker
this you go to palsadoo.com
foreign
all right here's what it says got a few
crumbs
oh [ __ ] here's my chromes okay all right
this one uh has a title which is can I
ask you something
this this poem is called can I ask you
something
have you ever seen the movie The Crow
a story of Revenge and sorrow
with Brandon Lee as the lead his
performance was so good I peed
my pants and hold on so doozy wrote
these [ __ ] poems yeah yeah all right
all right ai's doing all sorts of with
Brandon Lee's Lee he's performing so
good I Pete my pants and underwear and
shoes and socks crows have beaks and
crows have [ __ ]
some dude to make up the music the
premise the mode
the gothic the hairdos the lotion the
food what although I don't remember the
lotion or food
from opening scene to the final fight
those wet black hairs were true to like
so if you haven't seen it you're [ __ ]
up
go see the crow
you big dumb [ __ ] all right
that's good
all right uh this next one is called if
Al Pacino was a crow
boss of all the birds
commanding with a fierce car and ruling
with his beady eyes
he perch atop the tallest tree with his
wings spread wide and proud with all the
other birds and all the other birds
would see the Pacino was a crown
he'd swoop down with Grace and speed to
snatch up tasty treats to eat
and all all the other crows would meet
about how to worship His Crow feet
with his powerful voice and voice but
you know the crow would Reign a true
king of Disguise with an active skills
and brains
so if you ever see a crow
screaming and beating his chest chances
are it's Al Pacino
laughs
ruling over all the rest
that's Al Pacino I'll tell you no if you
ever see a crow screaming and beating
its chest okay
uh this is the next one it's called I
was supposed to be the crow agent sent
me the script and wanted me to be the
cop I said no I got to be the crow
they said they already got a crow they
just need a cop I said I already played
some cops let me be the crow
they said I could be the bad guy and I
almost said yes
but I said no I got to be the crow
went back and forth wound up doing
Frankenstein I was the monster but I was
supposed to be the crow
so De Niro was supposed to be the crow
but instead he played Frankenstein's
monster did you ever see that [ __ ]
Frankenstein movie he did not know but
[ __ ] no Christ dude it was hard it was a
hard one was that uh Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein yeah why do they call it
because Mary Shelley wrote Frankenstein
yeah that's a that's a way to get him
out she's a box office the you know the
in many ways the founder of modern
science fiction
I don't know who she was but
she wrote Frankenstein this one's called
I love crows
well that's how that's how authorship
when you write something brother then
you're the author dude yeah
all right
lots of noises come out of me when I do
this God me too dude this [ __ ] gets me
laughing so much and it hurts my throat
as well oh yeah I was laughing this is
uh I love crows I love crows black
feathers sharp beaks Kong Kong
clever I feed them every day table
scraps loose seeds crackers worms what I
talked to them too old stories funny
jokes names places that my friends
sorry good times good memories weddings
parties
he's going to Crow weddings
sometimes we fight
nothing serious you know stupid
disagreements economy baseball
oh
boom I like when they sleep little
noises strange dreams rest
night
Oh see it's in a dream I've never seen a
crow sleep never have one as a pet
better free no cage wild deadly I love
crows
laughs
oh that's a good one and uh finally we
have uh my Crow hat okay I was walking
briskly through Central Park when my
path was crossed by a shadow dock oh
feathers and Claws and big so long a
crow snatched the hat that I had on
he flew up a perch in a nearby tree and
looked down on my head gleefully he said
three years ago you stole my hat
you might not remember but this is tip
for tat I scratched my chin tried to
think back
and I did remember finding a hat that
was black
on a walk to a park just like today I
kept it and wore it in play after play
um
I was laughed at and and tried it and
jeered and mocked because the Hat was so
small
and it gave quite a shock to all who
beheld it balanced on my shop had
wondering if they could have it when I
was dead
but I kept it with me even after I died
a tiny Crow hat for my tiny Crow eyes
you see this whole time I've forgotten
to tell you the crow stole my hat
because I'm a crow too
I'm a crow
Sy
that [ __ ] was great there's all sorts of
ai's uh writing [ __ ] and doing this and
that but my gosh unreal dudes he cracks
me if Al Pacino was a crow man that's
tough oh that was [ __ ] tremendous